the zaparisian nuclear power station
sits in a strategic position near the
center of the southern front lines
the russians who now occupy and control
it blame the ukrainians for shelling it
over the weekend
the ukrainians who still have
technicians operating inside the plant
say that it was the russians
no nation in the world can feel safe
when a terrorist country strikes a
nuclear plant
god forbid something irreparable will
happen and no one will stop the wind
that will spread the radioactive
contamination
the nuclear power station was built in
the soviet era
three radiation sensors have apparently
been damaged and there was a power surge
but a russian news agency says that the
plant is still operating normally the
united nations has called for inspectors
to be allowed in any attack to a nuclear
plant is a suicidal thing and i hope
that those attacks will end
and at the same time i hope that the
e-i-a-e-a will be able
to
have access to the plant and to exercise
its mended competencies
the kremlin claims that ukraine is
preventing inspectors from reaching the
nuclear power plant and has accused kiev
of holding europe hostage
ukraine completely rejects that and has
said that the site should be a
demilitarized zone
the catastrophe on
the parisia nuclear power station would
be 10 times more powerful
than
chernobyl station and definitely that
would be suffered the whole europe and
the whole world
the parisian power station delivered 20
percent of the all energy balance of
ukraine
russian forces are sheltering the power
station in the belief that ukraine won't
dare hit it the u.s has accused moscow
of creating a nuclear shield
but it is in neither sides interests to
damage the power plant if radiation
leaks it could spread over ukraine and
southern russia
aleister bunkel sky news